[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the samsung galaxy note 9 an absolute
unit uh this is that android phone again
that starts at a thousand bucks this
year which is making headlines again
it's a very expensive phone i've been
using it since it came out since that
impressions video so for well over a
week
and i gotta say
i think it's worth it so last year i was
talking about the five pillars of a
great smartphone so if you recall some
of my previous reviews i've had about
five pillars of a great smartphone
those five and the one that the note 8
didn't have was great battery but
literally everything else about it was
great and it's still one phone of the
year
this year the note 9 upgrades
literally everything about that phone
and makes the biggest improvement
to the battery so it's getting a lot of
flack for being just an incremental
upgrade to the note 8 but i actually
think that's one of the best compliments
that you could give a phone right now so
what are those pillars again you might
be asking they are great display great
build quality great performance great
camera and great battery life i always
say if you check every single box you
got yourself a great quality smartphone
if we look at galaxy note 9 now it
checks every single box and then some so
the display is incredible some including
me would even say it's literally the
best display in any phone last year's
note was already the best display in any
phone this year it's 0.1 inches bigger
and it's magnificently bright you can
read it outdoors in direct sunlight it's
super vibrant and contrasty and color
accurate this is an a plus display great
for gaming for watching videos and also
no notch in case you forgot about that
the only downside to a display like this
is how big it makes the phone feel i
just came from the oneplus 6 as you know
with a smaller display and the pixel
before that and using an iphone 10 a lot
so moving up to this note it's one of
the few phones that really makes me work
hard to use it with one hand and i
prefer often to use it with two hands
and i don't say that about a lot of
phones so there's a lot of reaching to
get up to the top of the display and
then back down to the bottom and you're
going to notice it but then again if
you're getting a note you already know
what you're getting yourself into and
sometimes that's just something you got
to calibrate for but all in all great
display no question that gets a thumbs
up and that kind of leads me into the
second part which is great build quality
with the infinity display the kind of
bleeding of the edge of the screen over
samsung still does that it's
recognizable versus other phones that
don't do this and i like it they don't
have to reinvent the wheel here they
found something that makes it feel
really immersive and they just keep
doing that well but really i think we
just keep forgetting like the build
quality the industrial design or just
generally the hardware of this phone is
one of the most underrated things about
it it's really great you have the
premium build materials right so you got
metal all the way around this is the new
blue one that i actually kind of like a
lot
tight corners like really boxy as a
phone much more squared off than most
but i like that they still have the
rounded corners of the display but not
by a whole lot and then overall it just
has this chiseled dense look and feel
and it checks a lot of boxes it's ip68
water resistant it has a headphone jack
it has excellent clicky buttons and i'll
talk more about those in a bit
and one of the more underrated upgrades
to the hardware is the speakers they're
in the same place as they were but
they're now much louder and fuller
sounding and just straight up better
than before i definitely appreciate that
slight downside to the hardware is the
glossy back that will 100 collect tons
of fingerprints as you can see
as good as samsung's glass looks when
it's clean it can get pretty clouded up
but obviously the easy fix you can drop
a dbrand skin on it i may recommend a
black skin specifically for this one so
you can rock a super clean black and
yellow look with that s pen
overall this thing is built like a tank
build quality is not a problem on the
note 9. i'd even say it technically
counts as a little bit of an upgrade
because they move the fingerprint reader
down just a little bit to be more
reachable
minor detail but makes a difference when
you're using it every day but build
quality is great okay so performance
galaxy note 9 has been a great performer
it's a fast high-end flagship so you'd
expect that snapdragon 845 and six gigs
of ram here etc i'm always worried about
samsung's skin though because it's not
light it's kind of a lot you worry about
software updates with it but from my use
so far it's been smooth and snappy it's
what i've come to expect and it's gotten
one software update so far now this is
the 128 gig version with six gigs of ram
i haven't yet gotten to try myself the
512 gig version with eight gigs of ram
but the thing about that first of all
it's 250 bucks more expensive than the
baseline version so that's a lot
and then
i don't really see myself actually using
500 gigs of storage on a phone as
amazing as it is i love that it's an
option it's 2018 why not push that limit
but almost all the stuff i use as far as
media music
photos this stuff is all cloud-based
anyway if you are the type of person to
have an insane amount of local media and
movies and games whatever it is you're
doing there can only be one phone that's
offering this half a terabyte of storage
right now i mean maybe two or three but
that's what node is all about giving you
these power user features plus an extra
two gigs of ram doesn't hurt but i think
pretty much anyone including me will be
fine with the 128.6 and then there is
also a new cooling system to mention so
zack jerry rig everything he tore into
his note 9 and showed the much bigger
copper heat pipe inside this phone
samsung calls it a water carbon cooling
system all i can tell you is just from
using it this phone definitely still
gets a little bit warm on the back
especially when gaming for a while or
navigating in a warm window of your
dashboard or something like that but
definitely never overheated it is for
sure a great gaming phone though it has
the specs and more to keep up and the
most incredible display and some
upgraded speakers so that's still a
solid combo and so then there is the
camera or cameras and uh this is a this
is a firmly third place camera as far as
smartphones go right now which is pretty
awesome i mean you got pixel 2 at the
top which is amazing then you got this
and iphone 10 right around second and
third you can watch the blind test video
if you don't believe me but this is
essentially the exact same camera setup
as the galaxy s9 plus from a couple
months ago which makes it an upgrade
from the last note so just like the s9
plus you give it a lot of light and it
is an excellent camera you can get real
shallow depth of field if you get close
enough to your subject as they're pretty
classic samsung vibrant colors and
slight over processing as far as
sharpening and noise reduction you've
already heard this all from me before
the one new addition is the ai in the
settings which they call a scene
optimizer that will automatically adjust
certain colors when it recognizes the
subject so with flowers it might boost
the warmer colors or with landscapes it
might boost the blue of the sky
but i found this more inconsistent and
annoying to me than useful so i turned
it off after a while but what i do think
was useful is what they called flaw
detection or basically if someone blinks
or the photo's blurry or it finds a red
eye or something's messed up in some way
it'll let you know right away so you can
take another one that part's cool but
overall yeah so galaxy note 8 had a
great camera then galaxy s9 and s9 plus
had great camera now we got note 9 still
great camera so that brings us to what
you were all probably wondering about
from the beginning which is the battery
the note 9 bumps up to a 4 000 milliamp
hour battery which is a pretty big jump
from last year last year they were a
little conservative you know sort of
following up on the heels of the
problems they had so they had a 3 300
milliamp hour battery in note 8. so
that's a plus 20
battery capacity size that's not
iterative i know a lot of things we've
said about this phone have been
iterative that's not that is a massive
jump but that's just on paper so as far
as actual life of the phone goes it's
not the best battery life of any phone
that'll still go to phones with smaller
screens but note 9 is now comfortably
lasting all day with a little extra room
to spare which it didn't do that before
so i'm getting around 5 hours of screen
on time with most of my days
occasionally a little more never really
less
which with my heavy usage is pretty damn
good i'm going to say a minus grade
battery that i was pretty happy with
obviously having a massive 6.4 inch
super bright display cranked on all the
time is gonna take a toll on a phone so
we felt that last year with the big
screen i think four thousand milliamp
hours is actually the appropriate
battery size for the galaxy note and i
don't think anyone getting it will be
disappointed this is great battery life
so looks like they did it they they like
i said literally upgraded everything on
paper about this phone from last year
which was already good so i mean you got
a better bigger brighter display it's
great you got great performance you got
great build quality you got a great
battery life and a great camera now all
in one phone and like the note always
does it also has a ton of extras just
because samsung has tons of features to
throw in for people who are into that
kind of stuff those are people who are
buying the note like all the different
screen modes and advanced tinkering
samsung throws in the settings for
people who want to dial in the exact
color balance and look of their displays
things like that it's not it's clearly
not flawless uh such a perfectly placed
bixby button that can't be remapped i
can't ignore that it's a damn shame
i just want to remap the bixby button to
launch google or twitter or something
else i want to do what you can't samsung
i thought you were about that and the s
pen remote feature it works and it's
great i i just don't see myself using it
all that much i don't do powerpoints
from my phone or any presentations or
stuff like that
so i still just use the s pen for just
taking it out jotting down a note and
putting it away you know the extra
features are welcome and there will be
people who love them and use them a lot
but turns out i'm just one of those
people who uses stylus the way i always
have but for me at the end of the day
honestly i would have no problem using
this phone every single day it checks so
many boxes you can't really find another
phone that does an incredible high-res
oled display
no notch
ip68 water resistance a headphone jack
and then up to half a terabyte of flash
storage snapdragon 845 eight gigs of ram
expandable storage on top of that dual
cameras both with ois and a 4 000
milliamp hour battery a thousand bucks
is a lot to spend on a phone but if
you're gonna spend a thousand bucks on
one this is for sure the one to get
you're getting your money's worth and
people who are looking into buying a
note already know what they're getting
themselves into and they're gonna love
this but if you're in the other side of
that camp if you're not a note person if
you're if you're already typing in the
comments a thousand bucks is way too
much to spend on a phone i would never
do that then a phone like the galaxy s9
or s9 plus which are several hundred
dollars less that's going to be the
route for you to go so samsung's kind of
offering the whole wealth of different
budget options and you can choose and i
think you'll find something you like in
there it's a good phone good job samsung
until the next one thanks for watching
talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you